DANA PERINO, AND GREG GUTFELD.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
WE ARE BACK IN NEW YORK AFTER A
BIG DAY ON CAPITOL HILL.
BIG NIGHT FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP
ADDRESSING THE NATION AND A
DEEPLY DIVIDED CONGRESS ABOUT
THE STATE OF OUR UNION.
IT WAS AN INSPIRING SPEECH
FILLED WITH EMOTIONAL MOMENTS
HONORING HEROES, AMERICA'S
FOLLOWING, FREEDOM FIGHTERS, AND
MORE.
HE MADE A CALL FOR BIPARTISAN
IN THE ROOM.
WE ARE GOING TO BREAK ALL THAT
DOWN FOR YOU THROUGHOUT THE
HOUR.
WE BEGIN WITH THE PRESIDENT'S
THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY ANYWHERE
IN THE WORLD TO HELP THE NEEDY,
THE STRUGGLING, AND THE
UNDERPRIVILEGED.
I AM EXTENDING AN OPEN HAND TO
WORK WITH MEMBERS OF BOTH
PARTIES, DEMOCRATS AND
MY DUTY AT THIS SACRED DUTY OF
EVERY ELECTED OFFICIAL IN THIS
CHAMBER IS TO DEFEND AMERICANS,
TO PROTECT THEIR SAFETY,
COMMUNITIES, THEIR RIGHT TO THE
TOO.
HERE TONIGHT IS PRESTON SHARP, A
12-YEAR-OLD BOY FROM REDDING
CALIFORNIA WHO NOTICED THAT
VETERANS GRAVES WERE NOT MARKED
WITH FLAGS ON VETERANS DAY.
HE DECIDED ALL BY HIMSELF TO
CHANGE THAT AND STARTED A
MOVEMENT THAT HAS NOW PLACED
40,000 FLAGS AT THE GRAVES OF
WHO HAVE SERVED OUR NATION
REMINDS US OF WHY WE SALUTE OUR
FLAG, WHILE WE PUT OUR HANDS ON
OUR HEARTS FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE.
AND WHY WE PROUDLY STAND FOR THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM.
THIS ONE.
THIS CAPITAL, THIS LIVING
MONUMENT, THIS IS THE MONUMENT
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Jesse: AS MUCH AS IT PAINS
HE USED A LINE THAT YOU SAID ON
WE WOULD LIKE TO GET YOUR
REACTION TO THAT.
>> Greg: I SAW THAT, I WAS ON
THE TRAIN, SLIGHTLY TIPSY AND I
YELLED "THAT'S MINE!"
I HATE THE WORD CONCILIATORY.
I CAN BARELY SAY IT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS MORE LIKE A
DOUBLE DOWN ON HIS VISION.
IT SEEMED LIKE THE VISION WAS
DIRECTED AT AMERICA, AT
AMERICANS AND NOT THAT ANYBODY
ELSE.
I THINK I WAS WRONG BECAUSE ON
THE SHOW LAST NIGHT, I SAID HE
SHOULD KEEP IT SHORT AND SWEET
AND SAY HE'S NEVER GOING TO DO
IT AGAIN.
HE DID THE EXACT OPPOSITE.
HE WENT VERY LONG, LIKE
90 MINUTES.
I THINK IT'S BECAUSE IT WASN'T
YEARS IN THE DESERT AND COULD
USE 90 MINUTES IN THE OASIS.
IT'S LIKE, YOU'VE HEARD IT,
GREG GUTFELD, THIS ISN'T FOR
YOU.
THIS IS FOR AMERICANS WHO WANT
TO HEAR DIRECTLY FROM THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT WHY IT'S OKAY TO
FEEL GOOD.
>> Jesse: I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE DID FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT,
JUDGING BY THE REACTION.
DANA, WHAT IS YOUR THING?
I LIKE HOW THE ANTI-FOCUSES
BEACH ON THE PEOPLE.
>> Dana: HE STARTED IT BEING,
THIS IS NOT ABOUT ME.
IT'S ABOUT YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
HE BELIEVES THAT AMERICA CAN GET
THE JOB DONE.
THAT WAS WHAT THAT WAS REALLY
ALL ABOUT LAST NIGHT.
HE IS THE HEAD COACH FOR
CAPITALISM.
PICKING THROUGH THE ECONOMIC
HEADLINES WERE GOING TO TALK
MORE ABOUT THAT.
IT LOOKED TO ME, IT WAS A BIT OF
A LAUNDRY LIST BUT THAT'S HOW
THESE THINGS ARE.
I DON'T SEE HOW MUCH
FOLLOW-THROUGH THERE IS ON SOME
OF THE POLICY ITEMS YOU
TYPICALLY SEE IN A STATE OF THE
UNION.
LAYING OUT AN AGENDA SO THE
TO TRY TO PASS THIS YEAR.
ABOUT IT.
>> Jesse: YES, BUT I THOUGHT
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THEY DIDN'T SEE
IT MAY BE BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO SEE IT.
>> Kimberly: THAT'S WHAT WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT, KIND OF
REVIEWING IT, WHEN HE SAW HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT THE EMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS, EVERYTHING IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY, AND LOOKING AT THE
CONGRESSIONAL BLACK CAUCUS.
DIDN'T ACKNOWLEDGE OUR CLAP OR
SOME PARTISAN REACTION YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE MANIFEST ITSELF.
>> Jesse: NANCY NOT HAPPY.
>> Kimberly: OVERALL I FELT
THERE WAS A LOT IN THIS SPEECH
THAT WAS GREAT FOR BOTH SIDES.
WHETHER YOUR DEMOCRAT OR
REPUBLICAN.
I THINK IT WAS A VERY UPLIFTING
SPEECH.
ABOUT AMERICA, IN MY OPINION,
UNITED, NOT DIVIDED.
HE CERTAINLY HAD A LOT TO WORK
WITH IN TERMS OF THE COMPLIMENTS
HE'S BEEN ABLE TO MAKE IT.
MY FAVORITE PART WAS THE
PERSONAL STORIES THAT REALLY
I THINK THAT WAS THE BEST PART.
JUAN, DID YOU HAVE A FAVORITE
PART?
>> Juan: ONE THING I LIKED
ABOUT IT?
>> Jesse: BESIDES THE END.
>> Juan: THAT WAS IT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO BE
CONCILIATORY, TO QUOTE GREG.
EXTENDING THE OLIVE BRANCH,
SAYING IT'S TIME FOR UNITY AND A
GOING TO BECOME PRESIDENTIAL IN
THIS MOMENT.
HE'S FINALLY GOING TO PUT ON THE
JACKET AND ACT LIKE THE
PRESIDENT.
AND HE ALWAYS -- I AM LIKE
CHARLIE BROWN ON THE FOOTBALL
WITH THIS GUY.
OF HIS TALKING POINTS.
>> Greg: THE TALKING POINTS
WERE ABOUT UNITY.
>> Juan: NO, IT WASN'T.
>> Greg: ABOUT AMERICANS.
>> Juan: EVEN IF IT WAS ABOUT
AMERICANS, IT WOULD BE ALL
>> Greg: WHAT DID HE LEAVE
OUT?
>> Juan: SOMETHING SO
DRAMATIC, WHAT HE SAID ABOUT
IMMIGRANTS, AS A FAMILY, THEY
OF MS-13.
THESE PEOPLE ARE CRYING.
HE HAD SEVERAL PEOPLE WHO WERE
CRYING AND UPSET.
HE USED THAT QUITE
STRATEGICALLY, AS A DRAMATIC
REALITY SHOW.
>> Greg: NO ONE HAS EVER DONE
THAT BEFORE.
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT I WILL LEAVE IT
TO THE AUDIENCE TO JUDGE.
THEN YOU STOP AND THINK WAIT A
MINUTE.
MEMBERS OF MS-13.
>> Jesse: I THINK YOU ARE
CONFLATING IT, AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE DID NOT CONFLATE IT.
>> Juan: NEVER OCCURRED TO
ANYBODY AT ALL AND TALKING
ABOUT --
>> Jesse: SOME ABOUT ALL OF
BRANCH RIGHT NOW AND IS TALKING
ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> President Trump: AMERICA IS
A NATION OF BUILDERS.
NOW TAKE TEN YEARS JUST TO GET A
MINOR PERMIT APPROVED FOR THE
BUILDING OF A SIMPLE ROAD.
I AM ASKING BOTH PARTIES TO COME
TOGETHER TO GIVE US SAFE, FAST,
RELIABLE, MODERATE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT OUR ECONOMY
NEEDS AND OUR PEOPLE DESERVE.
>> Jesse: HAS A MAJOR
COMPONENT OF THIS 2018 AGENDA.
WE BELIEVE THE DEMOCRATS WOULD
GET ON BOARD SINCE THEY'VE BEEN
PUSHING FOR NEW INFRASTRUCTURE
SPENDING FOR THE LAST EIGHT
YEARS.
PEOPLE LIKE ME AREN'T CRAZY
ABOUT IT.
I HEAR INFRASTRUCTURE AND I HEAR
LEAST THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE
HAPPY BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE I'M
LOSING SOMETHING.
SPEAKING OF THE DEMOCRATS, CAN
WE TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT THE RICHIE
CUNNINGHAM HOLOGRAM.
JOE KENNEDY JR.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
LEADERSHIP, COMPARATIVE TRUMP,
THAT WAS A STUDENT COUNCIL
REACTION AND THEN I WANT TO PLAY
A SOUND BITE OF THE PRESIDENT
SAYING HE WANTS TO REOPEN GITMO.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> President Trump: TERRORISTS
WHO DO THINGS LIKE PLACE BOMBS
AND CIVILIAN HOSPITALS ARE EVIL.
ONE POSSIBLE WE HAVE NO CHOICE
BUT TO ANNIHILATE THEM.
WHEN NECESSARY.
WE MUST BE ABLE TO DETAIN AND
QUESTION THEM.
WE MUST BE CLEAR.
THEY ARE UNLAWFUL ENEMY
COMBATANTS.
>> Jesse: THAT IS SIGNIFICANT.
>> Dana: I'VE ALWAYS BEEN FOR
KEEPING GITMO OPEN.
THE PURPOSE OF IT, WHICH WAS TO
HOLD ENEMY COMBATANTS AND ABLE
TO QUESTION THEM AND THERE'S
BEEN THIS CONSTANT TENSION OF
SHOULD YOU BRING THEM TO THE
UNITED STATES WHERE THEY WOULD
GET ALL THE DUE PROCESS AFFORDED
GITMO.
HE WAS RELEASED.
WHERE DID WE CATCH THEM AGAIN?
OR HE'S OUT COME OUT THERE
COMMITTING TERRORIST ACTS.
TO HAVE IN THIS SPEECH IN AN
HOUR AND 20 MINUTES.
HE COULD HAVE PROBABLY LEFT THAT
OUT.
IT WAS USED TO NEEDLE THE OTHER
SIDE.
AS LOTS OF THINGS YOU COULD ADD
IN OR NOT.
I WILL SAVE OUR JOE KENNEDY, I
I DON'T LIKE TO GO AFTER
SOMEBODY.
I DIDN'T LIKE IT WHEN THEY WENT
AFTER MARCO RUBIO OR ANYONE WHO
DOES THESE RESPONSES.
IT'S A MISERABLE THING.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS HAD TO BE
FAIRLY HAPPY WITH THAT.
THEN THE WHOLE THING ABOUT THE
SINS OF THE UNCLE TWICE REMOVED
OR SOMETHING.
BUT IF YOU ARE A YOUNG DEMOCRAT
AND YOU FEEL IF YOU CANNOT STAND
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND YOU SAW THAT
IT'S NOT BERNIE SANDERS, NOT
ELIZABETH WARREN.
I'M NOT SAYING JOE KENNEDY IS
GOING TO RUN IN 2020 BUT IT WAS
DEFINITELY A CONTRAST.
>> Greg: BUT IT IS STILL THE
KENNEDYS.
IT STILL ANOTHER FAMILY.
IT IS TO LIKE HAVING THE
CLINTONS.
YOU ARE DRAWING FROM THE SAME
FAMILY.
>> Juan: IS IT LIKE HAVING THE
>> Greg: LISTEN, I'M TALKING
ABOUT POLITICAL DYNASTIES.
TRUMP IS NOT A POLITICAL
DYNASTY.
THE KENNEDYS ARE.
>> Juan: HE HAS HIS SON,
DAUGHTER.
>> Greg: YOU ARE COMPLETELY
MISSING THE POINT ON PURPOSE.
>> Juan: YOU THINK?
>> Greg: YOU ARE DELIBERATELY
BEING DENSE.
>> Juan: OKAY, I AM DENSE.
INFRASTRUCTURE, HE LAID OUT NO
I THINK IF YOU ARE SAYING LET'S
WORK ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE,
DEMOCRATS, YOU WANT TO DO IT,
LET'S DO IT.
CHUCK SCHUMER HAD AN OP-ED IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" YESTERDAY
SAYING THIS GUY IS TALKING ABOUT
PRIVATE FEES, MAY BE RECEIVING
GAS TAXES.
AMERICANS ARE GOING TO RESPOND
WELL TO THAT BIRD RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE GOING TO BE LEFT
OUT.
WHERE IS TRUMP ON THAT?
ARE DREAMERS TOO, HOW CAN YOU
NOT SEE THAT AS SOMEHOW MAKING
IT AS IF YOU OR YOU ARE THE
EQUAL OF A CHILD THAT WAS
BROUGHT HERE WITHOUT ANY
VOLITION ON THEIR PART, BROUGHT
HERE AS A CHILD, AND IS SEEKING
THE OPPORTUNITY TO FILL THEIR
AMERICAN DREAMS.
-- FULFILL THEIR AMERICAN
DREAM.
>> Juan: I WILL SEE THE LIGHT
DISTORTS THINGS AND THEN IT GETS
HEARD BY SOME PEOPLE AS IT IS SO
PUTTING DOWN PEOPLE.
>> Dana: THE POINT OF THE LINE
WAS IT HAS A DOUBLE MEANING AND
IT WAS MEANT TO DO EXACTLY
CONFIRMATION BIAS.
YOU ARE HEARING WHAT YOU WANT TO
HEAR.
>> Kimberly: INCREDIBLE
PERSONAL STORIES THAT ALL
I DIDN'T SEE IN ANY WAY HE WAS
TRYING TO BE DIVISIVE.
HE IS SAYING WE CAN PROSPER AND
GROW TOGETHER AS A COUNTRY
ESPECIALLY WE WORK
COOPERATIVELY.
FOR EXAMPLE, LIKE WITH THE
ECONOMY.
LOT OF PEOPLE.
WEIRD IDEA THAT WE ARE ALL
AMERICANS AND ALL DREAMERS.
PEOPLE THINK THAT'S WEIRD.
THAT'S SAD.
>> Juan: YOU NEVER HEARD
THIS OPTIMISM HAS BEEN AROUND.
PUTTING DOWN PEOPLE, AND YOU